le l'idée qu'on pollue ray ou qu'on
troublerait ou qu'on ne pèserait sur
l'élection présidentielle par la
distribution d'investiture pour des
élections législatives qui vont venir
plusieurs semaines après est une idée
baroque
en tout cas moi je considère que c'est
une idée qui qui n'est pas cohérente
tout le monde sait que quand il ya des
investitures ça provoque des sentiments
mitigés chez les uns et chez les autres
chez tous ceux qui pensent ou
souhaiteraient avoir ces investitures
c'est donc pas le moment
en plaine entre les deux tours d'une
élection présidentielle d'annoncer des
investitures aux législatives
en tout cas tel est mon sentiment
pourtant emmanuel macron l'a annoncé l'a
dit à plusieurs reprises il y aura une
vague d'investiture entre les deux tours
s'était dit encore la semaine dernière
on a joué en attendre beaucoup peut-être
l'at-il dit mais si j'ai un conseil
elle rappelle pas si j'ai un conseil à
exprimer c'est que il faut se concentrer
sur l'élection présidentielle faut se
concentrer sur la question qui est posée
aux français pour une fois dans une
absolue transparence que que voulez-vous
que soit l'avenir de notre pays vous
avez deux propositions politiques qui
sont en effet deux propositions
politiques qui ne qui ne disent pas la
même chose de la france et de l'avenir
de la france